how's it going bad my name is period of
hat and welcome to ninokuni wrath of the
white which the first heard about this
game I nearly jumped out of my chair
I don't think I've ever been this come
to play a game like I'm probably more
pumped to play this than even amnesia um
alright let's play on normal starting
anything yeah okay so yeah if this game
lets me down I'm gonna cry a lot
a [ __ ] lot but I hope it's gonna be
good I hope you bros want to share this
adventure with me there we go that's
four that's we're doing it I just bought
you right there go we're gonna have fun
Bret gotta have fun got down that is
pretty I hope this isn't just some
cutscene out this is you guys so I'm
good Shizuka Matt do go through the Guru
little cookie that was a jump scare is
he wearing a lantern in his [ __ ] nose
jesus [ __ ] christ who came up with
that idea they were high as [ __ ] when
they made what
Oh shet it's the Lion King all over
again
when I you couldíve I could I got you
know Queenie yeah
oh my I don't think I'd watch you go oh
yay back director title screen okay that
was a bit off guard I don't know about
you bros but I prefer in Japanese I
think you bros prefer Japanese -
actually I'm not sure I know some of you
maybe don't want to read and [ __ ] but I
think if you have the option to play in
Japanese and why the [ __ ] not
I already love the soundtrack it's all
really really beautiful um it's supposed
to be kind of long game too but hey I
like long games I don't mind that at all
if it's a good game it can last [ __ ]
forever for all I care um I really like
the style they do the 3d models and the
hold on jazz I think usually when they
try to make cartoons or anime is into
games it's it's not what you want it
looks kind of ugly and not nice at all
but I think they they really pulled it
off
another game that I'm looking forward to
this year is a softball game I think
they're doing the right approach on that
one as well
yeah oh [ __ ] I wonder who that is I
don't even know how you play the game
yet I'm really curious how it's gonna be
um what I guess the guy can keep [ __ ]
talking since this is an ending but
Japanese games have really been dying a
lot lately if she asked me like I
haven't played a Japanese game in
forever and a lot of people are saying
this is like the return of Japanese RPGs
or whatever um well say well see there
we go well that's all oh yeah that's
like anime cutscenes that's [ __ ]
awesome I bought I was so worried about
this game because I'm in a Lear ight now
and I bought professor layton and it was
in jail Italian and have no option to
switch to English
salomina basa horrible Oh hiya yo no
vendor asopao cheerio a select Oh keno
Marco Ganesha time oh no heart attack I
hunt oh yeah can you hate on de jour de
blanco' dokoni oh no yo Socky haitatsu
indica que todo por una cara Madison oh
hey near tomo yo are you Tony Lamas ah
ah okasan euros Kuna
all right
it feels like I'm in one of his movies I
don't know if high as a
hi-yaa hi-yaa hi-yaa Miyazaki is it
anything to do with this game I just
know the studio is working on it but I
guess he's part of the studio right
heroes feel free to tell me if you know
actually
oh it's felt cool yo really see this is
why I think this is why Japanese riches
are dying they're [ __ ] telling me how
to walk approach Philip and it will
press X to speak like do they really
have to tell me that you don't think I
could oh wow this is awesome
I really feel like I'm in the did a good
job that I had a name I don't [ __ ]
know hey what's up I managed to press X
all by myself how about that good thing
you found me guess what she's really
finally ready yeah oh my sound like a
dummy sit down I watch Miss Leila said
is it really what I think it is true
what else would it be
dum dum good boy young master guy boy
are you something else
Phil so what do we do now we ask what
else we take her for the spin Jeanette
yeah what Analia but I can't do anything
I see I mean I need to ask my mom and
Joe sunshine you ask your mom and then
why did we do it huh tomorrow next year
ha ha well I don't know but he said all
that by uh uh Japanese is impressive
good job ok I'll do it tonight but we'll
have to be real quiet
sure we will yeah mother boy yeah ok
tonight at my garage be there and peace
or be square huh oh man I have played so
much of this game already
gosh it's so this is a child who let's
save the world
hi or Standish should I read or not let
me know Goku no models yet you cannot
dougie do I think I'm not gonna like you
do then done in Nevada that Alice told
me all about the more chimas radiance
huh woody / holy bear oh it has an
interesting story so far uh the mini-map
will be played at the top right of the
screen as you travel around
well no [ __ ] [ __ ] it's mad lets you
see your immediate surroundings press r1
to switch on the kitchen map showing our
via the whole time Sarla to see where
you need to go next okay it's like maybe
I should go wait should I go Mamay where
the star is over there now just [ __ ]
go over here okay
I was playing persona 4 which is also
Japanese role-playing game and it's
exactly the same you just [ __ ] click
X X X X and it's like am I playing this
or am i watching a [ __ ] movie I mean
I don't mind to feel that it's a movie
that I'm playing by having rain for
example at least I feel like I'm doing
some interaction in the game or um I
don't know I only played for literally
like two seconds so I can't really judge
the game yet but I kind of feel like
what's up girl embody Oliver oh my just
look at all the leaves and branches all
over the ground hey uh what an awful
mess you're right
you have quite good you have quite
observing a belly up that's my house
it's beautiful [ __ ] nor this game I
have to say this is probably the most
beautiful game I played so far in 2013 I
haven't played that many games yet but
sell it's gorgeous
Gaza little payoff put it gonna hurt
how do you thought about don't ever
annoyed okay so grody Calcutta a money
lender Carter I start to nan cocktail
rack so you know I stole her car is okay
no Jessica tani-san Honda JA call you
have a higher Canaan iconic ma nice on
there yeah when I'm recording sauna it's
okay honey
oh wait till L please so Hector today
NATO [ __ ] when okra cheerio yo got
minute goes enough
kasa it taken an air intercept Arriba
cutes gettin it
mmm I like in every high FAL you hang on
it Scully at what the fine high school
Shmuel oh man I gotta use that one next
time today's special kid day kiddo
today's the day our dream machine father
rolls off the drawing board and onto the
street or motor well oh boy I can't wait
when can I see it
whoa there cowboy not so slow loud don't
forget this is our secret hey dum-dum
you didn't tell your mom about it did ya
no not after she was busy and she said
she was a part of country try so I'll be
in bed early
perfect then tonight's the night you
still in kiddo sure AM tonight at your
garage I'll be there I like how they are
purchase man purchase that is not gay to
have a man purse it is it has a very
good use you can put your wallet or your
keys there it does not mean you're gay
if you have a purse she must be asleep
by now for nipple dot needle she's out
like a light
that's my chance I have to go get I have
to get to Phil's garage all right so we
actually get to play no way press the
triangle to open the main menu you will
then be presented with a range of
options oh no I can't wait I don't know
about your brothers but I'd really
prefer to figure out the controls by
myself like I just think this is a
complete waste of time but hey it's my
opinion sometimes it'd give me hard to
through it yourself and it's necessary I
can exit the main door the mom doesn't
even [ __ ] notice all right that's a
good boy she's not at home is he where
all the people is it actually kind of
creepy I'm getting the creeper to be
Church can I jump over here I don't
think I can can i watch it there's okay
I get the map by doing that cool cool
now go away map
hey what's up why good evening Oliver
what are you doing out so late
that girl IRA with her observation
skills she should figure that I'm sorry
I just feel like interacting with
everything hello what are you doing Jed
it's late there's nobody around but this
motor bill I guess you'll be okay I want
to live in Motor Bell oh hi huh do you
want something I want mud I want your
ass I want a sweet honey all right do
that this is the way motor town bonus
here it is isn't it hola good lad
all right I'm coming even I up yeah it's
a secret she got inaudible no man
Costigan econo kinetically not ISA sorry
they can say Stano ah saigo no very no
motor it's cake and Yoda Mira Mira Mira
you shut well I'm really curious about
the it's a motorcycle isn't it yeah wow
he's really [ __ ] Emily Alex obsession
golem our clothes are a cocoon in Iran
are you dad Sasuke's intent Rika
oh all right you know what I get the
feeling this is gonna be an epic [ __ ]
game even though I don't get to play
anything I'm enjoying this okay there's
nobody around we should take her outside
now so Phil who gets to drive first huh
hmm let me see now tell you what kiddo
if you run down the street and make sure
the coast is clear I'll let you go first
you mean that oh boy oh [ __ ] boy okay
well right here I'll watch out for Terry
Mary will ya
Sarah Mary I send the girl in the window
you know the guy was spying as
before I swear that kid is crying poor
girl see as years again I bet I didn't
tell tell y'all straight to tell her old
yeah hello you [ __ ] talks she
wouldn't do that
what are you sweet on her or something
go check out out front
all righty sure thing bill I'll be right
back hello mates how you don't have a
nose Phil I don't know checking with the
coast is clear
all right it's kind of weird how the map
doesn't change but hey it's the cause
Claire wow I actually got to move there
for like five second I'm sorry if I'm
being ironic when I'm back I love the
game I'm sure I just I just think it's
weird how they never let you play in
this [ __ ] yes God every night Marconi
shot a organ again what yeah
[ __ ] yeah damn it Arriba Deacon
idea what kara kimi wa dos de poco na na
Mayo Arriba SOI SOI below me maka meets
katate dori knee
ah esto ahora su kun-hee dude she
teleported away one day old army noise
oh my god Oh RA cocina sake ma de Ternay
oh oh no no no no toasty Madoka Sarah
Mary can teleport it's also Tony did a :
icon yeah hey ma Kino Seder oh crap
Motors off mmm
okay so why the [ __ ] did he ask me to
check if it the coast was clear
if he was gonna come there any [ __ ]
way yeah I think he's tricking me to go
first because that thing is not safe
second squigglies I will save the world
Miroku Haqqanis Erica hey yogi no zone
en te hono tiro de wa totemo tada
Carrera engine Okaloosa tokyo marui
daleks kilometers
oh no token oh yah yah sevate avoids
kristen launch yakumo Matushka Nick
Ivana's I'm askin new oh she's radiance
yes madam and Ella gosh karate master
Luis us oh no what is that our gonna do
on that all is evil I knew that thing
wasn't safe Toto be exact I was gone too
soon
sure what she looks like Medusa Medusa
how do you say our name in English medic
medic medic
madam madam madam madam ma'am why is she
an octopus I mean what a mom's instincts
wow that's pretty badass
my buddies actor how did they translate
Oliver - sweetie
what alright avid ah-ha-ha
I know but I would actually be pretty
[ __ ] worried if my kid was not my
house late at night oh how late can it
be though it's a cute house I would love
to live in that town goddammit since I
have whatever Casa I start the non-car
she's smart
I stole her car it's okay no Jesse got
on it oh yeah oh yeah hi uh good night
Donna
Oh Madge you should have suspected then
know that he went that way
I hope she's gonna save him something
bad is gonna happen he's gonna teleport
into another world that's what I think
but goddamn I don't know all right let's
see what's gonna happen here yah yah yah
yah yah kukuda don't do it Oliver you're
gonna die
Wow
yeah it's crazy
yeah he's gonna enter another world now
don't you think
I'm not in the water
all right now did you know that if if I
car sinks then you see actually that is
impossible
oh yes okay
hatred movie just can't [ __ ] swim I
guess you didn't get [ __ ] sway
whatever a scary steady bar did it die
okay no I didn't know the end roll
credits
oh ha ha
comen casa la orilla kundo koto ni naru
nante no soul every sick economist ginga
Jeanne's na ma taught Scrivener oh sorry
tomo yo amo Karim s oh oh oh she's not
angry Dostana marker Oh took one secret
she's up there what hmm
what machine gun oh oh no but yeah
that's all I had time for today but like
a parrot if you enjoyed let me know if
you want to see more subscribe comforter
today and I'll see you next episode
that's why I'm a thousand breath mine
the little tag knock you out with all my
momma gonna stick your head in a rabbit
oh my god my heart